[Music]
it's been almost a year in this pandemic
and i could find myself saying
please god make this in
do we need a lucky charm to schedule a
shot in the arm if you've spent the last
few weeks fruitlessly searching online
for a vaccine appointment you're not
alone
a writer for the atlanta compares the
distribution plan
to the lines for cabbage in the old
soviet union who waits in line for
cabbage
because to get an appointment most are
sitting at their computer with several
links open
constantly hitting refresh hoping some
appointments will pop up somewhere
sometime before the end of time and if
you're not internet savvy you're out of
luck
biden blames you know who
my predecessor be very blunt about it
did not do his job in getting ready for
the massive challenge of vaccinating
hundreds of millions of americans he
didn't order enough vaccines
he didn't mobilize enough people to
administer the shots
he didn't set up a federal vaccine
centers
where eligible people could go and get
their shots
forgot that he's president now the white
house says they'll have 600 million
vaccines
by july so until then we keep on
clicking one guy in new york figured out
a way to streamline the info
from all those websites into one place
he calls it turbo vax and it's updated
constantly and he built the site for 50
bucks
so once again the private sector builds
a better product
which brings us to big government
remember joe biden's commitment to get
kids back to school in his first 100
days
i made a commitment that we try to get k
through
eight back to school by the end of this
100 days
we'll also do everything we can to
safely reopen the majority of our k
through eight schools by the end of the
first 100 days
yeah well that commitment has turned
into one
day a week in april when president biden
talked for the last couple
months particularly during the
transition about reopening schools
within the first 100 days
why didn't he ever mention the small
print that that was just going to be for
one day a week as the
goal well again the president made uh
set a goal of reopening the majority of
schools
within 100 days and when you asked what
that meant i answered the question
so we are uh that is the that is not the
ceiling that is the uh that is the bar
we're
trying to leap over and exceed a
salamander could leap over that bar
i could walk under that bar joe what do
you have to say for yourself
and now president biden on reopening
schools
that's right here's my schedule monday
going to school
tuesday to friday you stay home
zumba classes these kids love zumba
that ought to save some money right
there six or seven hundred bucks at
least
save your money for shoes all kinds of
shoes
cashews elizabeth's shoes
that's right if the shoe fits fairy
godmother says
you can go to the ball walk a mile in a
man's shoes
you can i'll make you a judge
[Laughter]
tyrus uh i can't even figure out how to
get a vaccine i have no clue
[Laughter]
we're just we're not important enough i
just i don't even know which way to go
but even people who need it can't get it
right i guess well you know i think it
just goes back to
i just i keep saying to myself over and
over again
the adults are in the room change is
this now the only thing we've seen
at a high level is executive orders
and the complete disappearance of
accountability
i get it things are more quieter now
that we don't have the tweets but we
also have any more
accountability because when someone
didn't do their part in the government
president trump had no problem pointing
out who's not doing their job now we're
back to the shadows
yeah now we're back to oh what we meant
was the bar
that's not even that's not even like a
chalk line on the ground
yeah one day a week it's i have children
actually as many as they're sitting i
have a lot but these are there some go
to private school and some go to public
school
all my kids in private school are a full
day
five days a week and when something
happens they make adjustments
public school they're on virtual
learning
and virtual learning is brutal because
you cannot make a nine-year-old sit in
front of a
zoom class with the technological
advances that they have today these kids
are clever
one kid literally wrote buffering as his
name
so literally the teacher was like oh
it's still loading
and he offered me his thing they're that
clever
my daughter took a selfie of herself and
positioned it in front of the camera
like this
and was off playing with barbie dolls
and i'm imagine if no one asked
her like what she meant by opening
school she's like well
over going back to school one day a week
does not mean schools are reopened any
more than
you know seeing your ex once we get 3
a.m means you're back together
it's like a cheap substitute and a joke
completely insane if no one asked if
she's like yes we're reopening that's
not reopening
as a former pop-up shop as a former
teacher it's completely insane
because you got one day a week the kids
it's gonna be like recess they're all
excited to see each other
yeah and then it's time to go and you
got to make up and then you got to get
them back it's
too much inconsistency for kids it's
fine for them because they don't
they have no accountability anymore it's
not their fault yeah yeah that's the
other administration
joe uh i don't know if you got the
vaccine i
my analogy for me is that i'm like group
nine
when boarding a plane for this vaccine
i'm like in seat 54j
that must be hard for you you're really
not used to that i'm not used to that
shut up how do you feel about this or
the schools or
well i i think one day a week does equal
a full
week of school in the same world where
we're two weeks to flatten the curve as
a year
yeah but it just seems to me
it's extremely frustrating because the
the government does the easy part hard
the hard part was getting the vaccine
yes and the easy part should be getting
people to get it
having a clear process for who gets it
when and it doesn't seem to happen like
that and that's what worries me about
single-payer universal health care i
think most conservatives are willing to
have the conversation that we need to
get
everyone covered with health care in
some fashion but should it be just the
government
well then we're going to need more
governments because there's got to be
some sort of competition
because this stinks right or look at the
website too like the super confusing
you know website this guy can do for 50
bucks it's like you know yeah the
government's always the most efficient
way to do things
they could have done that for 50 billion
though right exactly i would say i bet
it was you know and then it would jam up
yeah yeah they probably spent a lot more
than fifty dollars for this bunker i
have to get a loan from the nigerians
they can only yeah they can only they
can they can make a website
for 50 billion that jams up like a 1982
printer
remember those yeah that works like it
runs off a commodore 64.
yes or something like that yeah two of
the most frightening words government
portal
yeah yeah yeah government portal this is
the nature
of government and bureaucracy
bureaucrats and politicians come
in and take something that is crystal
clear
and obvious and make it inefficient and
non-functioning kids do not transmit
even if they had the virus do not
transmit
the virus like adults do they're less
likely
to get very sick from it the science
says
get them in classrooms